[Musique]
donc
vous avez 84 ans ce n'est pas rien et
vous publiez en allemagne en italie en
france en angleterre un livre qui
s'appellera en français dans trois
semaines chez claire la faune amoureuse
de l'amour qui a été un petit peu
réécrit par notre ami dans teva qui est
qui est un livre qui raconte votre vie
qui est assez extraordinaire faut bien
le dire ce qui justifie que nous soyons
venus vous voir ce soir à munich
alors quand on essaye de comprendre un
peu votre personnage quand on essaye de
comparer qui vous aide à des gens que
les gens connaissent peut-être un petit
peu mieux que vous on pourrait penser à
marlene dietrich à greta garbo et on le
verra tout à l'heure un petit peu eva
braun aussi et si on voulait raconter
votre vie en citant des films on
pourrait citer cabaret on pourrait citer
les des années et on pourrait citer le
dictateur parce que vous avez très bien
connu à la fois adolf hitler et charlie
chaplin
alors quand le livre commence deauville
vingtaine d'années vous travaillez dans
un unique vous cous et des pyjamas en
soies vous vivez dans une petite pension
qui s'appelle la pension rothaine style
et puis vous avez très envie de danser
le soir quand vous rentrez chez vous
après avoir cousue vos pyjamas en soies
toute la journée vous mettez votre
grammophon tout indice sur grammophon
et puis vous danser comme ça devant la
glace et
vous espérer qu'un jour quelqu'un va
vous découvrirez espérer qu'un jour
j'aurai une grande danseuse une grande
star ce qui est d'ailleurs arrivé par la
suite la question je vais vous poser
c'est que les jours vous allez voir
rudolf nelson qui est le premier à vous
faire confiance à vous engager dans sur
une scène de théâtre
finalement est-ce qu'il vous engagé par
ce qui vous a trouvé très joli ce qui
était le cas et ce qui est encore le cas
même à votre âge est-ce qu'il vous
engager pour ça vous parce que vous avez
cédé un peu à ses charmes
ils ne se connaissaient rien de moins je
n'étais pas danseuse et je pense que ça
l'a impressionné que la personne jeunes
comme je l'étais ose demander si elle
pouvait danser chez lui un théâtre très
reconnue avec des danseurs de très
grande qualité
il l'a essayé et ça marchait ensuite
vous vous lancez dans le berlin des
années 20 vous fréquentez une société
bourgeoise un petit peu décadente et
vous dites dans votre livre que beaucoup
de gens prenais de la cocaïne à l'époque
alors quel effet ça faisait quel effet
ça fait la cocaïne quand on en prend
j'avais un cercle d'amis tout le monde
je prenais la cocaïne
tout le monde me disait il faut
l'essayer c'est extraordinaire je
l'essayé une fois j'en ai pas pu dormir
pendant 24 ans 24 heures et donc c'était
la dernière fois que j'avais pris mon
sommeil était quand même quelque chose
de spécial que je voulais pas sacrifier
[Musique]
vous dites dans votre livre à un moment
qu'un vous avez pensé que vous étiez
devenue lesbienne et ça vous faisait
peur est ce que vraiment c'était dans
votre tête ou est-ce que à l'époque où
vous avez eu peur d'être devenue
lesbienne
vous avez eu vraiment des relations
homosexuelles avec d'autres femmes
non c'était j'étais ce type de femme je
dois être femme qui venait toujours vers
moi et
et c'était la mode à se tourner avec un
château à odom avec un grave acte iv
on a pris seul
m josé et j'ai tant que jouer le jeu et
j'ai tout essayé j'avais des amis eux
extraordinaire mais il fallait faire
très attention de ne pas disparaître
dans une pièce lors des défaites qui ont
aidé mais vous savez que
l'adolescence la jeunesse à chaque
époque la spécialité il y à une souris
ou des choses qui n'a rejoint très
favorable mais il faut passer par ces
choses je vous devez tout essayé j'étais
très curieuse alors c'est à cette époque
où toute façon vous n'avez pas céder au
culte de sapho parce que vous avez
rencontré votre pygmalion qui était le
baron à haubold phunsy dalle qui vous a
amené un jour d'ailleurs aux studios
universal et qui vous a plus ou moins
dirigées vers burnat ou qui vous a fait
jouer dans faust alors c'est lui qui
vous a un petit peu appris à vivre avoue
conduire dans la vie à vous tenir à
table à bloquer en société il était plus
âgée que vous est ce que ça vous
demander un effort de vie finalement
avec un homme plus âgé est ce que vous
vous donniez du mal ou est ce que
voulait me réellement ils n'étaient pas
plus âgés que moi il est décédé jeudi à
4 ans et jusqu'à cette époque là on
était amis mon éducation a été très
simple c'est effet de fonctionnaires
lorsque je suis né
un père était musicien et un oncle a
fait de lui plus tard et fonctionnaires
parce qu'il pensait que le musicien
c'est un métier dans lequel l'on ne
gagne pas suffisamment d'argent donc mon
éducation était simple et il m'a
beaucoup appris des choses qu'on apprend
seulement dans de tels certains milieux
il était un peu comme un père et comme
un ami et 10 à influencer imprégné toute
ma vie c'était une amitié extra je les
skis pour couper mes mauvais mais je
n'ai pas assez mais pour l'épouser bien
sûr mais mes parents aurait beaucoup
aimé que je devienne raconte s mais
notre amitié a duré jusqu'à sa mort
c'est l'époque où vous découvrez la côte
d'azur que scott fitzgerald vient de
faire découvrir au monde entier
vous voyez j'ai beaucoup vous allez à
berlin bien entendu à rome à paris à
londres
et vous connaissez toujours cette vie
assez exceptionnel qui a été la vôtre
faut bien le dire
et à ce moment là de chaplin vient vous
voir en allemagne accompagnée de
griffiths et il vous dit cette chose
tout à fait pensable à l'époque il vous
dit cet autrichien avec la petite
moustache
moi il me plaît pas beaucoup alors ce
que je vais vous demander c'est comment
à l'époque comme quelqu'un de
l'importance de chaplin avec cette
acuité
cette intelligence vous mettez en garde
contre hitler qui était en train de
commencer à faire parler de lui
étiez vous inquiète ou pas de la montée
du nazisme tout simplement
[Musique]
il n'était pas le seul à mettre en garde
mais on n'a pas voulu le on ne pouvait
pas le croire
vous ne pouvez pas croire ce qui nous
attendait il y avait plusieurs personnes
qui savent fesses et d'espacé ils ont dû
y aura et lichens et durera jusqu'à ce
cas aucune pierre ne se trouve sur
l'autre mais on ne pouvait pas se
l'imaginer nous on était apolitique on
n'avait aucune idée
et à l'époque on ne pouvait pas le
prendre au sérieux
seulement plus tard on a su on a vu ce
qui ce qui se passait au moment où on a
pu observer ces gens de plus près moi
par exemple j'ai trouvé ça très chic
lorsque monsieur l'aïe a vu hitler a
rendu visite à hitler tout était très en
fait tout était
après d'excellents jeux et on est allé
avec les autres et sans savoir que
c'était et 100
imaginez ce qui se passait plus tard en
on en revient à charlie chaplin puisque
c'est la fameuse scène qui l'a illustré
dans une dictature mussolini vient
rendre visite à hitler charlie chaplin
rythmique et l'histoire du train qui
avançait qui recule et du tapis rouge
qui ait jamais la bonne place alors vous
rencontrez mussolini dans un dîner en
présence de hitler goebbels et mussolini
devient le duce devient très très
amoureux de vous il est il est fasciné
par votre regard vous vous êtes pas
insensible à son charme latin et vous
dites dans votre livre vous c'est un peu
incroyable quand même parce que
finalement si on écoute votre vie on a
l'impression que tous ces gens là vous
avez fréquenté mais vous avez contenter
de vous baigner la nuit avec
vous laisser un petit peu car et c'est
l'épaule là vous dites que mussolini
vous a offert des friandises et une
photo dédicacée
est ce que maintenant à votre âge vous
pouvez avoué certaines choses est ce que
vraiment il ne s'est rien passé d'autre
que ça avec benito mussolini à l'époque
non non ce n'est pas vrai c'est take or
pay avec les friandises et avec cette
photo encadrée en l'argent a été un
cadeau de monsieur m'a été envoyé par ce
que avec une seule ligne
j'ai beaucoup flirté c'est à dire que
lui apporter avec moi et moi j'ai
répondu à ce froid bien que beaucoup de
femmes de très belles femmes
cette occasion là et d'une invitation au
milieu la hitler campbell et nous on a
été
demande et on nous a demandé de venir
cette réception la dent côté des femmes
société nous on était les actrices et
vous pouvez bien s'habiller en cavale et
j'appelle avéré que c'était un type qui
plaisait aux femmes monsieur nenê
vraiment impressionné
femmes c'était un homme très très
masculin profil mais hitler et gober ça
je dois dire malheureusement de saison
c'était vraiment éclater la mutinerie
qui avait éclaté en 1939 hitler décide
de faire arrêter le tournage d'un film
dans lequel vous étiez qui s'appelait
les esclaves blanche parce qu'il
trouvait que les communistes étaient
montrées dans ce film d'une façon d'être
un peu trop positive par la production
décide de vous envoyer en mission auprès
de goebbels avait comme objectif de
faire reprendre le tournage du film vous
allez voir goebbels il vous emmène en
voyage d'ailleurs dans un dans un wagon
qu'il avait fait aménager un petit peu
vous dites comme un bordel du début du
siècle et vous faites un voyage de
berlin avait marre avec goebbels vous
arrivez dites-vous à lui échapper à
échapper à ces assauts amoureux mais par
contre il vous faire attraper
et il ya cette scène digne d'un film
absolument extraordinaire il vous fait à
mener dans un chalet de montagne par des
ss et là que s'est il passé
la direction de la troupe ne va pas
réussi
faire le fil nylon humilité on essayera
ça avec une femme parce qu'il savait
qu'en bob bell son aimé les fins et mais
toutes les faims c'était vraiment un
consommateur incroyable de foot et gabès
a profité de cette suite ne m'a pas fait
venir dans sa chaussette moisi il m'a
fait venir dans un chalet qui était
niché dans une halte dans la montagne et
moi toujours avec mes manuscrits sous le
bras et l'a bien dit hitler m'a permis
de je viens de faire tendre
modifications dans le film pour qu'il
corresponde à notre méga pas fait
attendre cette affaire tirant non cette
affaire et je te fais toujours faire ce
voyage à 100 km
dans la direction de brême dans une
forêt
très
à gérer des dossiers et
un petit à petit s'est approché de moi
même
cris n'a pas avancé il a changé des
frères que j'ai montré à ma soeur et qui
m'a dit c'est fou c'est complètement fou
ça s'anime entre pas ça ça tout gâcher
parce que à l'origine que tu étais pas
fait pour que je ne peux pas il est
parlé personnellement
j'assure ça m'arrangerait bien possible
il a essayé tout avec toute femme on
disait qu'il était
vraiment elle avait une manie c'est à
dire qu'une femme quittait et de quitter
l'autre on ne savait plus assister à des
des dîners avec les dignitaires nazis
vous avez pu finalement vous retrouvez
dans ce chalet en train d'essayer de le
corriger le script des esclaves goebbels
vous avez fréquenté leurs femmes vous
avez fréquenté leurs petites amies et
jamais vous n'avez pu obtenir une
information plus précise sur la vie
sexuelle d'hitler non 27 ans avait
survécu les femmes l'admirais l'adoré et
une fois j'étais dans un hôtel éclat et
y faire passer je sais plus qui s'était
c'était une actrice qui s'est précipité
vers la fenêtre j'ai dit oh mon dieu
notre fureur et moi je pense à volos
québec puisqu'elle est imbécile et elle
a presque pleuré de joie et je ne
comprends vraiment pas et je n'ai déjà
dit tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que c'était
qui a fait que des femmes réagissent
comme ça moi je ne comprenais pas mais à
ce sujet et il voulait être adoré comme
un saint on vivait 39 km 40 km de munich
en pleine bavière dans une région qui
finalement depuis la la fin de la guerre
n'a n'a pas complètement changé tout le
monde le sait est ce que votre votre
attitude de face aux questions que je
viens vous poser est est ce que vous
avez peur de répondre est ce que vous
seriez menacée si vous disiez des choses
sur l'époque aujourd'hui non bien qu' on
ne sut on ne sait jamais on a bien on a
beaucoup de nazis encore et j'en ai
connu quelques-uns avec qui j'ai discuté
à la noce
ils ont tous une à une excuse ça
mannum sympathique parcs d'importance
mon dieu que j'ai fait quand j'étais
jeune six ans je suis entré
or les colorer côté et je n'ai rien
appris d'autre que d'obéir et
il lui a été repris par hitler plus trad
et dans une certaine mesure je comprends
lorsque vous aviez 20 ans et que vous
couzier vos pyjamas en soies vous
habitiez chez une charmante dame juive
comme vous dites dans votre livre qui
s'appelait madame rothen stein est ce
que vous savez ce qu'elle est devenue
pendant la guerre non car et 6,3 les
mavs il ajouté je les lui rendu physique
quand même et bien qu'ils me disent
toujours
ne venez plus et un jour on m'a dit elle
a été
arte à ce moment là on ne pouvait plus
faire de recherche est ce que ça voulait
dire
c'était une vieille fille vraiment très
charmante emma qui ne fait de mal à
personne
est ce que maintenant à 80 ans passés
même si vous lui faites pas du tout est
ce que vous regrettez d'avoir été mêlé à
tout ça finalement
et ah oui vous avez toujours vécu dans
un grand luxe que ce soit berlin pendant
la guerre ou avant la guerre ça soit
hollywood est aujourd'hui finalement
vous avez perdu votre maison de
roquebrune cap martin qui a été saisie
par le gouvernement français à l'issue
de la guerre vous habitez dans une
charmante village enfin dans un
appartement qui n'est pas très grand
alors comment vivez vous aujourd'hui et
surtout de quoi avez vous aujourd'hui
avec quel argent pouvez-vous subsister
aujourd'hui parfois je me pose la même
question
j'ai perdu plus encore
j'aime aller du ray allen par un soit-il
sens
amis j'ai perdu tous mes biens il est
parti à l'étranger où l'agent est vrai
d'une halle où il a par la suite après
la guerre j'en avais plus rien ou rien
du tout la ferme été nommé plus rester à
la maison et donc c'était peut-être ma
propre confort c'est essayer de faire
court tout mon possible g j'avais
toujours pas plus que son sac à main
tout est donc ses bijoux était très
important et c'est avec ses bisous j'ai
pu acheter racheter une maison là
son est à peu près 5 hydrate ici
vraiment dans un endroit extraordinaire
c'est une très belle ville avec plus de
4000 mètres carrés et j'ai besoin de
deux personnes donc c'était trop de
travail et
à ce moment là je me suis dit c'est trop
travail je vais m'acheter cet
appartement et ainsi me reste plus de
temps pour mes violon d'ingres super
star est sans doute dans la fin notre
existence un peu seul il ya une star qui
vit encore plus seul que vous à paris
avenue montaigne qui s'appelle marine
d'être riche et dont la carrière est un
peu phare est la vôtre finalement et que
je vous souhaite de rencontrer lors d'un
voyage à paris pour la sortie de votre
livre
est-ce que vous comment vivez-vous la
carrière de marianne les triches par
rapport à la vôtre que pourquoi
finalement at elle beaucoup mieux réussi
que vous aussi vous pouvez répondre à
cette question
marlene vatry marne l'aisne était plus
intelligente elle a toujours gardé les
uns sidéral il était plus consciente et
elle l'avait
elle voulait réussir plus que moi quand
j'avais un rôle j'ai essayé de faire le
mieux
bon vous avez raison marlène avait les
mêmes chances que moi cette possibilité
moi j'avais le régisseur moore now qui
l'avait découverte
ensuite il comptait les états unis et
c'est enfin une ride
il avait laissé le message que au
prochain film il voulait travailler avec
moi madame écrit en velin c'était
l'homme qui croyaient en moi qui m'avait
découvert mes marques
marlène avait sternberg qui lui étaient
restées et je pense personnellement que
la plupart des femmes qui sont devenus
des candidats avaient un registre
producteurs qui croyez 100%
en disant ça voilà c'est la femme qui
est la femme et qui va réussir et qui
voyant star à 100% et sur ce qu'est le
président de united artists et aux
etats-unis voulait m'épouser
il était très sérieux et voulaient que
je divorce et ça c'était un homme qui
croyait beaucoup plus tôt
à ces attaques le président de yu-na est
à karaté c'est plus tard l'un des hommes
les plus importants chez fox lui aurait
pu faire un star mondiale de moi mais je
n'étais pas toujours dans les bonnes
mains
après ce bon baisers soeur j'avais été
régisseur qui n'était pas très bon et
moi je suis très dépendant des résultats
j'ai besoin de quelqu'un qui croit en
moi qui crois que je suis capable de
faire des choses des choses
extraordinaires et avec marlène j'étais
comparses dans le film anges et cordes à
kikwit arrêtées sans mandat qui était
moi je le connaissais très bien c'était
l'un des premiers qui me
fait être compense donc lui je
connaissais quand j'étais très jeune
mais elle elle l'a fait comme il faut
pour ma part j'ai fait des choses un peu
bête
plus vous êtes parce que l'allemagne
parce qu'il y avait des sentiments et
marlène n'aurait jamais ne l'aurais
jamais fait
[Musique]
la navette avait proposé et et j'ai
rencontré cet homme dans ma vie la rhune
mémorial par exemple nouvelle gens ont
fait des choses pareilles parce qu'elle
voulait faire carrière à mu et moi je
n'ai pas fait de sacrifices pour la
carrière et je crois qu'il faut faire
des sacrifices qu'il faut vraiment être
possédé
par-delà carnières pour devenir
quelqu'un
[Rires]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu